[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] It
's been a very tense campaign
including a campaign marked by
violence and deaths that's how
worried you are about the campaign and what
could happen after the election this is
unprecedented in the history of Brazil
this started with  a violence of
people linked to bolsonaro incitement
to violet a little similar to what
trump did in the United States in the
naked truth is that we are
living in a climate of violence that we
were not used to living here in Brazil,
you know  want to run a campaign and
try during the campaign process
to politicize Brazilian society so that it
becomes better informed that it
becomes better aware of the things we
want to do for Brazil
that's why I
containing this violence I think that
electoral justice and the  the political class
has to keep an eye out because if we are
not careful now, that is,
instead of having an election, we may have a
demonstration  about canavalism you know
canavalism is what
we didn't know I
honestly think that
Brazilian society has to be very attentive so
that we know
see Who is committing violence
because they are committing violence who
is putting Brazilian democracy
at risk
because  We in the PT appreciate Democracy,
we live and
practice Democracy. Now it seems to me
that our opponent doesn't like
democracy, let alone practicing it.
There are these acts of violence and this climate
of violence.
they are
violent as you would try to
pacify and also reduce the
polarization that exists in Brazil if you are
elected president
we will pacify the country because as
we win the elections
we assume the government first we
will govern for everyone according to this
country  there is a constitution and everyone has to
obey this constitution, the third
party will make sure that  society is a
participant in the execution of our
government program, we are going to set up a
government that goes far beyond the PT, a broader government
with people from various sectors of
society so that we can carry out
good governance in this country and the
question that
more than ever  any other about how
we can trust a government than a
party that participated through
party members or also
Allies in a corruption scheme the
size of a car wash. Do you accept that
the party and its allies made a mistake?
I want to tell you
something, fighting corruption is
something that the PT has done like no one else,
including punishing people in the PT who
have committed the PT. I'm tired of
apologizing for the PT's mistakes.
who made mistakes be
investigated be know investigated
Invest the prevention of Innocence and if
busy people are condemned then
the role of a political party what  My
regret about Lava Jato is that Lava Jato
decided to leave the process of combating
corruption for the process of
political combat because I consider myself innocent, you
know, very innocent and I think that if I
win elections, people can rest
assured that we will continue
very strict to investigate any
accusation of corruption let's go to the
economy
calculations made by Fundação Getúlio
varga this account that the average growth
in Brazil I entered in 2010 and 20 was only
one point three percent per year
what your government would do to encourage
Brazil to  grow faster
on average 4.5
it is important to know what happened
when the PT governed this country I
intend to hold
a meeting with the governors in the first week and
survey which
infrastructure works are priorities for each
state so that we can  create a
pact between the federal government and the
state government to regionalize the
economy the BNDS will once again be a
development bank  olvimento Banco do
Brasil will once again encourage small
and medium-sized Rural products and small and
medium-sized companies, a savings bank will once
again invest in this basic element and
we will go back to building millions of
each in this country, that is, then the economy
will return to  work because in a country
that considers itself capitalist it has to have
capital and it has to have credit what we
need is to strengthen the possibility
of an Industrial policy Brazil already
had 30% of its GDP that was linked to
industry today this type means 10 11
per  cent that is then Brazil needs to
go back to believing in an
industrialization process and it is not Brazil
alone it is not the entrepreneur alone what
I think is that there has to be a combination, you know,
state, companies and universities
so that we start to discuss What
type  of industry we will want
to create What kind of product will we
want to produce so that Brazil
becomes competitive productive knowledge for
that we have to c  keep investing
massively in education we have to
keep doing it University knows
training a lot of engineers in the area of
communication
so that we can be competitive
that our zero priority is to make
the Brazilian people not starve
my priority was to guarantee that
everyone takes  breakfast and dinner every
single day
This is my priority
to make the poor less
poor so that people can live with
dignity you know how poor people and
one of the basic things we
guarantee food we have to guarantee the
emergence of job opportunities and
this comes in the area of ​​civil construction, which
is an area that generates many jobs, which is, you know,
the issue of Housing, a question
of basic sanitation Highway, railroad,
which Brazil needs a lot but doesn't have
much to do
[Music]